[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
interval thank you so much for coming
out tonight thank you thank you it's
we're so happy to have you here it's we
we have these occasions sometimes when
we're not only presenting a program
we're really proud of but it's actually
a project of long now it's work that
long now has is is part of our mission
and and part of the folks who work with
every day so it's really exciting to
have been talking today and we're yeah
you're in for a real treat
I'd like to ask you it brand co-founder
of long now co-founder of revived and
restore to come up and give an
introduction for tonight's speaker
thanks Michael so if you get the New
York Times so it's Tuesday so it's
science times Tuesday and on page 2
there's a quote that's taken from an
article in science magazine that came
out this week on the extinction and the
quote is if this is always going to be a
zoo animal then stop the goals have to
be about ecological restoration and
function the quote is by Ben Novack the
speaker tonight how is it that Ben's
being quoted in new york times in
science magazine when this animal went
extinct just over a century ago nobody
could believe it would happen because
there had been billions of them maybe
five billion in North America's most
abundant bird in the world everybody
said yeah it's being hunted is terrible
but it will never go extinct there are
so many of them so when they did go
extinct and I remember my mother telling
me about this in the Midwest and now
they broke everybody's heart
it shocked everybody into realizing that
continental animals could go extinct up
till then only island animals like the
dodo and or the Great Auk had been known
to go extinct and so these birds
probably saved the bison which were in
the process the next continental animal
that was being hunted to extinction
so as a result of this iconic quality in
2012 when I was on the stage for assault
talk with Tim Flannery a biologist from
Australia in the Q&A for some reason I
just said hey Tim what if we brought
back the passenger pigeon we were just
talking about the firelight idea of the
extinction and he said strong harmony
who might and go ahead and do it so I
wrote George Church the bio
technologists at Harvard who might be
able to do such a things that she'd
mentioned it in his book Regenesis he
said sure let's do it Ryan Phelan who
now directs reviving restoral run the
Q&A put together a meeting at Harvard
about bringing back the passenger pigeon
with various specialists one of whom got
in touch with some random kid who turned
out was wild about pigeons named Ben
Novack who then got immediately in touch
with George church who got in touch with
us we then hired Ben Novack without
actually meeting him sort of that's an
intern to go intern at George church's
lab at Harvard Medical School and learn
about the next level of dealing with
biotech for ancient DNA and one thing
led to another - eventually he was
coming out here to go to UC Santa Cruz
and while he was doing the science
across all of the various projects
reviving her stories doing he was also
getting a master's at UC Santa Cruz and
just this year he got his master's
degree Brian and I were there
practically moved to tears liking
awesome parents and it was pretty
interesting because a lot of the
heavyweight scientists at UC Santa Cruz
were there being very impressed by what
his research had turned up there was
serious news about the passenger pigeon
and that's what you're about to hear
tonight Ben
[Applause]
am I on am I on
alright everyone can hear me fine
alright so I'm gonna go right in my talk
I very rarely finished these on time but
tonight is going to be an exception so
some of you may have been at Stewart's
salt talk back in 2013 anybody in their
room hit that yeah there we go
and we've been talking about this
project for a while everything in
Stewart's introduction happened in 2012
and we went public in 2013 with a series
of talks Stewart on Ted and then we had
our big event TEDx the extinction where
the world finally got to see me and my
bad hairdo for that day and this
eventually led to correspondent with the
National Geographic magazine up on the
wall over there that came out about
de-extinction and so I mean then the
world's conversation about passenger
pigeons and whether or not we should
bring them back started no project
happens with one person I lead the
project and what that means is I effect
functionally do the least amount of work
and try to find the best people to do
the rest
all of these people and these
institutions have played a vital role in
making everything we're gonna talk about
tonight happen most of all Ryan and
Stuart right there so the last three
years of research what have we been
doing with with long-nosed time and
money well we've been doing genetics
paleo ecology and you're not really
supposed to care about the images that
are on this slide but I do want to point
out that this right here is an actual
visual representation of the entire
passenger pigeon genome that it that
represents 990 million base pairs of DNA
and a single figure and so it's a very
important figure not yet published but
that is one of our most important
figures in our research so far you can
ask me about that when the talk is over
so it was brand new news a little while
ago that band-tailed pigeons were the
closest relative of passenger pigeons
and not mourning doves so
subsequently the last century no one had
ever bothered comparing passenger
pigeons and band-tailed pigeons so
that's something we had to do brand new
for the first time comparing skull
measurements and other things related to
my work and relating that to dietary
ecology so all of this over the last
three years eventually culminating in in
that proud moment
that's my selfie from the bleachers
after getting my my degree you can see
my you can get my master's thesis online
if you look it up it's not the best
piece of written material the new
publications will be better but the
thing is something to know about extinct
animals is if anything goes extinct
before 1830 there's been no scientific
treatment of it whatsoever
ecology wasn't a science until the 1930s
so even though there are a century of
publications on passenger pigeons no one
had treated them scientifically in a
modern way and that's what the real goal
of rewriting the history of the
passenger pigeon was and I want to start
out with chapter one and it's supposed
to be a coy and vague title for a reason
what is the extinction this is revived
and restores definition of the
extinction this is not yet published but
this is the definition of de-extinction
the extinction is a form of ecological
replacement by means of purposefully
adapting a living organism to serve the
ecological function of an extinct
species by altering phenotypes through
means of breeding or genome editing
I know it's wordy and horrible but we
have to be this way in science the goal
is ecological function so what was
quoted in New York Times that's that's
the real goal for us might not be for
everybody but that's what it is for us
so the extinction can happen in a number
of ways as I said through breeding
trying to recapitulate the phenotype of
an extinct species using some living
species such as the quagga project
that's been going on since the year I
was born or the Oryx project in which
they're using the actual descendants of
an extinct species the Oryx to bring
back together the genes that have now
gone through independent lineages or if
you have no living relative that you
could breed in there
wäôre no descendants that you could
breed in the right way our approach with
genome editing for some of the most
unique animals in the past now this is
not exactly brand new the world's first
engineered organism is the red canary
which was done back in the 1920s and 30s
through breeding engineering is
technically just bringing the genes of
one organism into another organism so a
few people bred yellow Canaries with the
red Siskin birds that are come are very
distantly related and you get this
representation of a genome this is what
I want you to focus on right here one
chromosome from one parent one from the
other then they read those and when you
re breed you get recombination and so
you get this little mixed chromosome for
the first time this very new hybrid
chromosome with some from the red Siskin
and some from the yellow canary and then
you start interbreeding those offspring
one generation at a time until you have
just the traits you want left over and
you get a bird that's red but is a
canary I want you to pay attention to
that genome because people often tell me
that what we're doing is somehow novel
and brand-new and it's never been done
before and it's so unnatural but look at
the genome of what a d-- extinct
passenger pigeon looks like we're just
moving the genes of one organism into a
related organism for those selected
traits just like was done almost a
hundred years ago with the red canary
we're just doing it with so with modern
technology that we can get that DNA from
a bird that's no longer alive now there
are natural analogues to this this is
not something that's just in the
engineering realm red wolves are
actually hybrids of two species they're
not a species that evolved on their own
when people sequence the genomes of
those wolves
sometimes they're 75% coyote versus wolf
Beth Shapiro is lab has been working on
polar bears for a long time it turns out
almost every living grizzly bear in the
world has polar bear genes from
hybridization events that happened
30,000 years ago and those polar bear
genes have been acted on by selection
for various Reed's
reasons and this is the one I really
want people to take home all of us
tonight
how many of us are from Africa not or
not originally not originally
genetically African okay you're actually
not don't fall into that trap because
you're not genetically African because
once people left Africa they ran into
someone called a Neanderthal and
everyone here in this audience tonight
is a hybrid so however pure we want to
view ourselves or however we peer we
want to view nature it's not simple we
are all hybrids that hybridization event
happened 45,000 years ago and evolution
has kept traits that work for us from
Neanderthals and gotten rid of the ones
that don't so what is the origins of the
original passenger pigeon that's what
we're gonna talk about so think about
that D extinction but let's think about
the passenger pigeon as a whole now its
evolutionary history and the reason I'm
opening up this way is because this is
the long now so we want a long view so
let's go back 15 million years and this
is a completely made-up bird that I
painted Columba pata genus progenitor or
the the the creator of the american
pigeon so a bird that might have looked
like this existed 15 million years ago
that we do know and what's special about
that bird is it arrived in North America
and it began a cascade of really
interesting events over the last 15
million years 12 million years ago it
made a split into two different lineages
and the lineage down the west coast
where we're at right now spawned the
band-tailed pigeon you might have seen
some of these in your backyard every
once a while or out hiking and those bet
that lineage continued on down into
South America and diversified into
multiple species into all of the
different environments that exist there
and there's so many species that
diversify that I had to split this up
into two animations because there's a
couple different waves of evolution that
occurred creating 17 different species
in 12 million years and that's
incredible that's absolutely incredible
but arguably what's more incredible is
what was going on with that one
population in eastern North America all
that time
what was going on something really
incredible happened here a bird that
started out breeding the way any other
bird starts out had an evolutionary
awakening and all of a sudden birds that
are territorial decided to start being
colonial and nesting near each other
this allowed them to take advantage of
the forests that were very expansive and
perform larger denser flocks it also
increased their need to develop social
selection schemes if you're competing
for mates next to a lot of other males
you need to be showy I think a lot of us
know that tonight and this creates one
of the only sexually dichromatic pigeons
in North America and one of less than
possibly 20 or so in the world which
eventually becomes the bird that we know
today that lived in that range and the
birds that you're seeing here tonight
males with red breasts and blue wings
so how do we know this how do we know
this well a few years ago some people
sequenced some DNA notably Beth
Shapiro's lab and they found how the
passenger pigeon was related to all of
these other North American pigeons and
but what they didn't know is that was
when all of this stuff happens so Andrei
Suarez and I sequenced the genomes of a
bunch of other pigeons including the
dodo and these are mitochondrial genomes
it's a funny thing just look that up on
your phone and we were able to time this
event of pigeon radiation about 12
million years between those species well
what's been happening the environments
have been slightly consistent so we
looked at the environments of where
band-tailed pigeons live here in the
West and passenger pigeons in the east
and the Rocky Mountains form a large
barrier and the Great Plains form a
rather consistent somewhat permeable
barrier over the last 12 million years
while forests were continuous so we
synthesized out all together to make the
story that I gave you just now and on to
the next chapter so you now know how the
passenger pigeon came to be now we're
going to talk about what the passenger
was pigeon was doing once it had that
evolutionary awakening and it's it's a
really key thing observed in the 1800's
was this phenomenon that you have a
patch of closed forests and a band of a
billion two billion passenger pigeons
give or take a hundred million come
through and they do what pigeons do they
poop a lot but because there's so many
they actually break trees break branches
because they're trying to find places
say they and the reason that it's
believed they have the name passenger is
because there were so many that they
would crowd and land on top of each
other as passengers and as they settled
eventually a region of forest sometimes
up to 30 square miles sometimes up to
two eight hundred square miles that
those the largest event averaging 30
square miles would be just absolutely
devastated and as modern people we think
that's an absolutely horrible thing how
could that be good for the forest
well devastated forests undergo
regeneration and they offer new homes to
a variety of animals that closed
canopies don't producing this type of
system
successional types of habitat from the
disturbance back to closed canopy in
which different species utilize at a
time so the same patch of land can
temporally hold more species than any
individual habitat at any given time
now what passenger pigeons were doing
for the past fifty thousand years was
moving nomadically from one patch of
forest to another every few weeks doing
this so the tens of millions of square
miles of forests of the eastern United
States was being constantly seeded with
these new habitats creating a mosaic of
regenerating forests that means you had
mature stand next to a recently
regenerating stand next to a middle
stand so it created a large habitat that
was just prime for most species that
live there today how do we know this
this was the main thing missing from the
passenger pigeons story people have
speculated about natural history and
ecology a great deal but without being
able to sequence DNA and do population
genetics we could never really get to
the heart of the passenger pigeons
history so what have I been doing for
three years we've sequenced the
mitochondrial genome this little tiny
circular piece of DNA that you get only
from your mother mother's in the room
yeah you guys are genetically more
important than men and we can because
you only get it from the mother we can
figure out relationships very nicely we
have it from some published data that we
didn't do it's always nice when someone
pays the bills for you but we have toe
pads such as from this bird right here
so it I can take a tiny little cutting
from the toe of this bird about the size
of a pinhead and get the entire genome
about 10 20 times over not just that
genome I mean the entire genome we have
a couple from the 1690s and really
amazingly from bones like that we have
4,000 year old DNA from passenger
pigeons now we might have ten thousand
year old DNA might we haven't dated the
bone but we have a mitochondrial genome
that we haven't included in any of our
analyses because we haven't paid for
dating the bone yet because we have just
enough bone left for one dating run
they're very light and we're due because
we keep debating are we gonna do this
but it might be ten thousand years old
and it's identical to the ones from the
1800s which is pretty astounding so what
is passenger pigeon history population
history there's been some ideas this
absolutely ludicrous idea that they
became abundant only when Europeans
disturb the habitat published in the
book 1491 by a guy who probably didn't
read anything else and this published
curve that starts out based on
population genetics but based on an
erroneous calculation and then ends with
the idea that they were dependent on oak
trees so oak trees were not prevalent
until 10,000 years ago so that's the
idea that they boomed up then we put
together a hypothesis that if they were
dependent on the types of forests they
bred in in the 1800's that maybe that's
the curve or maybe just the ice age dip
to them and then they came back
something like that we had all these
hypotheses with great reasoning and we
felt really confident that we would know
the story until we got this back and we
spent several months wondering what the
hell that means this is actually not
even truly real what we've discovered
from the nuclear genome and the
population genetics is that one
passenger pigeons have been extremely
abundant the number up there is
approximately an effective population
size
that's a genetic population size of 7
million someone here guests for me the
genetic population size of human beings
who have 7 billion people on the planet
it's from but it's between 10 and 15,000
and theirs is 7 million that's bigger
than any other published bird to date
and it's been that way you'll notice
pretty consistently for 20,000 years
they they don't react to anything that's
changing in the environment and this was
the key thing that changed our
understanding about the bird now what it
has this special date here of 45,000
years they went up and down but what
we've learned from the nuclear genome is
that's a that's a screwy date so huh
that's an evolutionary selection date
that is not a population date odds are
what was happening
these birds were abundant for hundreds
of thousands of years and that the
genetic diversity was going up and down
while the population wasn't and it's a
very neat phenomenon that we'll be
publishing in our paper that was
predicted in the 70s and this is the
first real-world data that proves that
phenomenon when you're abundant it
shapes you so what do we do it that we
have that key piece of information so
we've been relating it to diet we've
been relating it to changes in the
habitat over the years creating a
synthesis of what this bird was doing
and what it was like going over other
published literature on this bird and
going okay now that we know this new
thing what does it mean based on what
they were saying and it turns out all
the data you would ever need don't even
bother reading that I'm just showing you
that I did a lot of work all the data
you would ever need to put together the
natural history of a passenger pigeon
exists in some other study that never
bothered to talk about pigeons things
about interacting ecosystem drivers in
oak forests disturbance dependence
histories of different tree species the
the early value of early successional
habitats to Eastern forests disturbance
dependent bird conservation etc all this
stuff you read through it all realizing
something about passenger pigeons and
you come to these kind of major points
one passenger pigeons were ecologically
resilient
that's that straight curve going through
ice ages and changes in habitat and not
even blinking they were superb
generalists that's why they were so
resilient their dietary impacts shaped
forest evolution that's the main point
of my thesis and their abundance made
them ecosystem engineers of that mosaic
system and that's been their role for
this ongoing bit of time and that's the
reason we want them back why today well
no oh I'm getting ahead of myself
between 1800 and 1914 this was going on
you have your billions of birds and
because they were so easy to shoot and
net eventually they go extinct now
recent research shows that it is human
harvest that is the major force that
caused the extinction of these birds not
deforestation
any other impact not some behavioral
issue in the birds don't believe most of
the stuff you've heard about passenger
pigeons because as we've just shown you
tonight with this new data we've learned
most of it's not true
and even though it's really sad I just
kind of smile that little train qohen
pine full of pigeons food so in the
1800's and I'll just take this aside
quickly meat markets were fueled by wild
game and that's because you have an
influx of immigration making the
population human population boom without
the establishment of ranches and farms
on the scale that we have today
those were just growing so most of the
protein that was going to the markets
it's wild game at the turn of the last
century almost every large game and game
animal in the eastern United States was
virtually was almost gone people don't
understand that deer which are seen as a
pest could not be found in the forests
of Appalachia in 1903 practically
because they hunted everything these
were so abundant that they were easy to
get a lot of at once and they were just
happened to be the first extinction in
inline which is why all those other
species did not go extinct what's
happened since then there's been heavy
amounts of deforestation but something
really cool is despite the fact that the
human population has skyrocketed you'll
notice that reforestation has really
come back there are places the eastern
forests are virtually the same forest
cover today as they were in about 1830
which is really impressive but it's
slightly different habitat and there's a
reason for that
without any more disturbances we've
suppressed fire we were suppressed any
type of disturbance all of those
successional habitats are disappearing
and so despite having more habitat today
than for a hundred years all those
species are in decline and what you'll
find in the literature is that most of
our iconic species of eastern North
America will be extinct within the next
century in the eastern United States no
matter how much you protect the habitat
no matter how much you do to restore
that habitat manually those we
go extinct in certain places and likely
will go completely extinct in each
United States simply because we now have
closed canopy forests that are different
than they used to be so the reason we
believe and I believe very firmly I
think the data supports it that we want
passenger pigeons back is they can do
this scale of engineering producing
these environments that we could never
do on the scale that's needed we can
burn we can chop we can do whatever we
want but you know what I drove by I live
down by Monterey drove by a fire this
morning controlled burns do you really
want that in your backyard
the alternative is cleaning up some poop
every once awhile I mean between burning
your house down or cleaning off poop I I
mean I think it's it's pretty obvious so
how are we gonna do this engineering the
engineer I'm actually gonna finish way
ahead of time that's good this is the
basic process we've developed over the
past few years of how any form of avian
genetics will work we have to go from
informatics sequencing DNA and figuring
out what genes matter and then we need
to put those genes into a cells get
those into birds breed up those birds
and so on and it's much more complicated
than that these have to be for birds
especially that to be a very special
type of cell called a primordial germ
cell and even though I'm not talking
about he's hens tonight I'm going to
bring them up for the fact that revive
and restores Heath and the extinction
project is making really good
advancements in developing these
resources they've been proven this is
the technique used to engineer domestic
chickens and it hasn't gone beyond the
chicken because no one in the world has
ever needed and needed to go beyond
chickens for their work but we want to
bring this into the realm of endangered
species extinct species and it's not
easy but the heath hen might be the
first to prove make some real break some
real ground there but following that
we'll be pigeons you can ask me why the
pigeon is behind right now and it's it's
unique traits of the bird it's nothing
it's no no sign it's not it's not some
sort of obstacle preventing us from
going there first
it's just heath hens are easier
so my goal I have the picture of a
band-tailed pigeon here but I really
hope we actually put those engineered
band-tailed pigeon cells into rock
pigeons because they're easier to work
with in captivity will grow up a whole
bunch of passenger pigeons when you
breed those chimeras so essentially you
have a bird that's a rock pigeon and on
the inside it's growing the gametes of a
engineered passenger pigeon breed a male
and a female you get the passenger
pigeon for the first time in a hundred
and twenty years or so and then we start
working with them in captivity
acclimating them to the wild I want my
birds to be our birds it's very close to
me I want our birds to be wild from the
moment they're hatched so I don't want
them to grow up in a laboratory a
setting or an aviary setting I want them
to be growing up exposed to weather in
very controlled settings with settings
that are actually just netted areas of
forest and that's going to be key I
believe to getting that setup
preconditioning etc and eventually we'll
take down those nets and let them fly
and they'll get to rediscover themselves
in their habitat and start doing for us
what they used to do in the past I
believe it'll only take about ten years
with the right adequate of resources and
money from the point where we start
breeding these birds it could take less
than ten years to get a population of
10,000 10,000 is arguably perfectly fine
to make a sustaining population people
believe we need billions of these birds
for them to sustain and that's that's
kind of lunacy for two reasons one
there's no evidence in the past that
passenger pigeons are required large
flocks to live but two this is not the
passenger pigeon of the past the genetic
basis that forms this bird is a
band-tailed pigeon birds that live in
flocks of 10 or 20 a bird that has a
population of about 2 million total
right now it's not a bird that needs
large flocks to live and what we've
learned about the genomes which i think
is really amazing what I was alluding to
earlier is that if we give these birds
the the essence of the passenger pigeon
we give them the the kickstart they need
the traits we want to include to create
this bird this new bird pata genus neo
octopus tease the new wanderer of
America
if we give it this these traits it'll
assume the evolutionary trajectory that
happened 12 million years ago and even
though that bird does not have
necessarily the complete genome of a
passenger pigeon from 1860 passenger
pigeon genomes have a very unique
signature it's not inherent in what the
a's t's c's and g's are it's inherent in
the diversity across that genome and
it's made it's formed by a history of
abundance so when these new birds that
can start off at a small flock become
abundant I guarantee you that the ben
novack of the future who may be bonita
Nova Corps who knows when they sequence
DNA from these birds they will have the
same genomic signature as they did in
the past and that will be the true
recapitulation of the extinction and
that's why it's a long now project so
what have we been doing let's give you
the more technical view in 2012 I got on
board with reviving her store with DNA
from three passenger pigeons and that's
the only reason I really got my job
that's what's missing from this as I
came to the board with something no one
else had privately-owned passenger
pigeon DNA that was not had no strings
attached to an institution but it had
one string attached and that was me and
we used those samples to figure out some
aspects of passenger pigeon DNA quality
which who then would set us up
for working with best lab later we
attempted a band-tailed pigeon genome
that summer at George church's lab and
me having never done it before didn't do
the best job in the world so that genome
didn't become the reference genome but
it is there being very valuable to our
research today when I came to Beth's lab
we've sequence DNA from 4140 to
passenger pigeons to start doing this
work I did DNA extractions of 87
individuals three of which turned out to
be rock pigeons
which was cool I'll write about that but
uh it was disappointing to say the least
and and we've sequenced two complete
nuclear genomes now the other paper that
published genomes did genomes too so we
actually have four complete nuclear
genomes of the passenger pigeon where
you might have five in a few weeks and
the more you can have the easier the
work actually becomes so the actual
reference genome of the band-tailed
pigeon first started sequencing in early
2014 and it was a disaster it was
actually easier to work with the dead
birds and it was the living birds it we
failed seven times in two months and
that is very disheartening but this is
not like this is not unique to me being
a novice at that point in time this is
just if you ask anybody who does this
work they're like yeah we had this one
animal and it just would not work at all
but by early 2015 we finally with the
help of dovetail genomics down in Santa
Cruz had one of the world's best
reference assemblies at that time it's
still not published but it was one of
the world's best they've continued to
top themselves at every turn though so
it's no longer one of the world's best
but it's very close our our greater
prairie chicken genome of the heath hen
project actually was one of the first
genomes they did and had and beat out
the domestic that chicken at the time
that was awesome for us
so so we began mapping these genomes to
chicken genomes and other things trying
to figure out chromosomal patterns all
things that don't really matter right
now but are scientifically important and
we figured out very early on and this
number will be revised but we figured
out that there are 25 million mutations
between the band-tailed pigeon and the
passenger pigeon we're after the 10 to
100 mutations that actually work on
those traits it's important to remember
that in 12 million years a lot of
mutation builds up that means nothing
and here's why is anyone here tonight
not a human being no no one's a
different species
some of you have a lot more Neanderthal
DNA than others no no we all consider
ourselves human but between every single
one of us are thousands of unique
mutations some of them significantly
large and we don't view ourselves as a
different species now and that's because
in hundreds of thousands of years of
being human you get unique mutations and
they don't affect anything that makes
you human they affect things like the
size of your eyebrows or the receding
hairline you have this is not receding
by the way my wife keeps telling me how
to receding hairline it's been like this
since I was four years old this is just
it so 25 million mutations that's just
grown over 12 million years of time
evolution only acts on the ones that
really affect key traits so it might
only be 3 or 4 genes that influence
colonial behavior we've actually
identified one of the genes involved in
making the red breast and that comes
from the red canary genome research that
other people did and that's one of the
reasons I brought it up tonight so in
2000 late to early 2016 late 2015
we began finishing the final draft and
began actually discovering where those
genes are it turns out that's a
laborious thing to do you can find them
by their sequence but finding them is
it's just it's a pain and I'll never do
that again I'm outsourcing that I'll
never do that again people other people
you can outsource it if you can
outsource it to people who are better
than you pay the extra money so in 2015
Crystal bioscience another Bay Area lab
that's pioneering gene engineering and
chickens they're one of the only labs in
the world that's ever had success in
culturing cells of birds other than
chickens and we are partnering with them
on our Heath hen project and we want to
partner with them long-term on Pat on
the passenger pigeon project so they
began a pilot study just figuring out if
you're working with pigeon eggs rather
than chicken eggs what's the best way to
do it and so they identified what stage
to harvest cells haven't grown any
successfully yet but that's our next
push is getting to the point where we
can supply them with an
funds so that they can figure out how to
culture pidgin cells and we're
negotiating with potential partners at
Texas A&M right now for developing a
pigeon flock to be used for this type of
research because once we have the cells
that doesn't really do us much good if
we can't make those cells into a bird
again a lot of work goes into that about
we assume there now that about five
years of research would need it'd be
needed for that project and possibly
anywhere from 500,000 to a million
dollars would pay for that segment of
research and really open up the field
for a lot of other birds that's the
bottleneck technology for avian
de-extinction as a whole so if you want
to see dodo birds or great ox or
anything else we got to invest in that
technology and the passenger pigeon
could be the one that really opens up
the door after the heath hen for various
reasons we did a really great study with
a man named Paul Marini who is a very
quietly spoken man who you wouldn't
believe his achievements by meeting him
but anyone ever eaten turkey or chicken
in the room so like 80 percent of the
chicken and turkey at the markets in the
United States are derived from a line
that Paul Marini bread selected for
traits he was a quantitative geneticist
and he sits down he says Ben you know
all this genetic stuff much more
advanced than I do and I'm like no I
don't Paul but he loved birds and he
wanted to help so he set up an aviary
and he bred two pairs of band-tailed
pigeons from Sal Alvarez for six months
to figure out can you get them to lay
more eggs what can you do and this was
very valuable for us because when we're
gonna breed these birds it's what let me
say we could get 10,000 in ten years we
have a report on that online and of
course with all that DNA work we were
doing I was putting together ecology
over the past three years figuring out
that history of abundance and what it
really means all the way to the end of
to that
2016 where we finally interpreted their
full niche that's what we've been doing
what do we want to do next in there we
go
it would have been nice in 2016 to get
this started we haven't yet we're still
talking to partners but we want to start
that cell culturing experiment with rock
pigeons and eventually moving that into
working with band-tailed pigeons the key
experiment we want to do first is if we
can get cultured rock pigeon cells we
want to turn we want to create some test
those and rock pigeons we then want to
create fantail pigeon cell lines and
pass them through rock pigeons that will
be a key key first step if we can get a
band-tailed pigeon to hatch from a
street pigeons egg then we have proven
we can make a passenger pigeon and once
we've done that we can start genome
editing experiments in those cells we
can start introducing the traits that we
feel are the ones that are going to be
important for passenger pigeons and over
the course of a few years in a cell line
we can do hundreds of generations that
would have been happening in real bur I
mean in live Birds introduced those into
a single generation of parents and
leapfrog forward in evolution so to
speak until we have a breeding flock
sometime maybe around 2022 where we can
start come on there we go start
propagating them at multiple locations
we have some volunteers that do pigeon
racing people who are award-winning
pigeon racers who are interested in
helping us out with this now and of
course moving to the closed habitats
this is how the pink pigeon was restored
in the wild and Mauritius I just visited
there a few weeks ago got to see some
and then of course our target dates
sometime in the next decade getting them
to a sustainable population sauce and I
have even though I said I was gonna be
early I have managed to go one minute
over time this is the long now view of
extinction this is what we want to do
and with that we'll go to questions
brilliant thank you Ben
so while you are all thinking of your
questions I have one for Ben and I think
it's very amusing that you think that we
hired you because of your passenger
pigeon DNA when we really hired you
because we knew you were hardwired to
bring back the passenger pigeon so why
is that it's because there was no one
else crazy enough to commit seriously
Ben why are you passionate about this
where does that come from well I'll make
a plug for Marino Connor right now
Marino Connor Maureen O'Connor wrote a
book called resurrection science which
is a chapter about this project and she
has a very good personal treatment of me
and it basically if you read anything in
media articles they'll say that I love
these birds since I was very young my
grandfather had birds growing up and I I
got bit with the pigeon bug early and
when I was 13 years old I thought that
the extinction was the logical next step
for conservation I grew up I should
premise this I grew up in Western North
Dakota about an hour from Theodore
Roosevelt's ranches in the badlands now
to me that area is the true mecca of
conservation and national parks not
Yellowstone because it was there that
Riviera Roosevelt became a Conservation
it's inspired by that landscape that's
what I grew up in and growing up there
we learned a very great deal not about
how pristine nature is but how managed
it is and how much people are involved
in the land and and so for me the idea
of ecological restoration going to
extinct species was the next step things
like putting wolves in Yellowstone
that's the extinction beavers in
Scotland that's the extinction it's just
not to the point that we can do with
this technology and so I wanted to
pursue it and I fell in love with it and
we're glad you did
first question yeah actually Ryan I want
to first of all introduce the other
co-founder of reviving restore Ryan
Phelan who's gonna be running Q&A for us
I have a question from the stream and
then we'll we'll get a question right
over here what is the likelihood that
revive and restore will be allowed to
release a significant population of
passenger pigeons into the wild and what
is the legality of this
this is a question we have been looking
into since we started this work and what
can be definitively said right now is
that there is no regulatory policy that
absolutely prohibits us from doing so
but there's no regulatory policy that
absolutely allows us to so so some
reworking of policy is necessary and
that's where it comes down to our
supporters the only way we're really
going to advocate and get strong support
for these projects in the regulatory
framework is if the public comes out and
says they want this to happen
public opinion shapes how the US Fish
and Wildlife Service operates 100% more
so than the scientists involved I can
tell you that if people are gonna eat
them someday it'll be regulated by the
FDA yes yes it will be now the there's a
transgenic American chestnut right now
that's going through the regulatory
process that will be the world's first
genetically modified organism that could
be approved for wild release and so we
view this as a very very fruitful time
to be thinking about these projects and
helping to go through and think about
beyond a plant how do you regulate an
animal now revived and restores
black-footed ferret project it stands to
be the first project to engineer the
cells of an endangered mammal in the
world and we're doing this under the
auspices of permissions permissions in
certain ways from the program and US
Fish and Wildlife Service so we view
these as projects that will help build
the regulatory framework and even though
regulation seems to go slowly
I think there's high likelihood that
when we have enough birds to put in the
wild we will be allowed to put these
birds in the wild but that that depends
on public support all right go ahead so
you said that you only need about 10,000
of these birds to make the ecological
change that you're looking for versus
that hundred thousand are millions of
birds how are they gonna do the damage
or restorative in that pack so so that
might have come off confusing 10,000 is
the number of birds that that is that is
sustaining or or can survive in the wild
without blinking out it's highly
unlikely 10,000 birds will make an
ecological blip it's more likely that we
have to get up to a million or more
birds and the more birds you have the
the larger region you get to cover with
that that's something we're trying to
look into we really don't know the
density of birds needed to to break tree
branches and this is something anyone
could do in their backyard please do it
we have a guy in Massachusetts and he's
been doing this for a year and a half
and I said could you just weigh down
branches and figure out how much weight
you need to break it and he went out and
he made little bags passenger pigeons of
sand based on their average weight put
him up with hooks and the branches bent
all the way down to the ground they
didn't break and then so he put on more
he's like okay so this is passenger
pigeons on top of each other's backs
they didn't break and he thought well
maybe it's because the branches were too
low right he's too short so they were
hitting the ground so he then went out
with a bow and arrow and shot up over
arrows and he couldn't do it with with
so he got a barrel and he put water in
the barrel and went until it broke and
he finally broke one but you know we
need more replicas so this we need to
figure out what is the density needed so
we can start scaling this can you
imagine what this guy's neighbors
thought yeah this is what happens when
you get volunteers riding revive and
restore saying they want to help
yeah all right next question yeah so the
the environment that you're gonna be
releasing these pigeons into has been
pretty radically radically altered from
what they would have lived in in you
know before humans expanded in or before
Europeans expanded West into the
Americas is there any evidence that
they'll resume the same ecological niche
that they had when when they lived in
well the only way there would be
evidence is by putting them back
ultimately the ecological niche is based
on density population density so this is
something that we will be able to we'll
be able to get the first glimpse is that
in captivity if the birds are not
densely flocking or socializing then
they'll never recapitulate that and we
haven't got there yet so before we ever
bother releasing in the wild we want to
see that they are densely socializing in
captivity differently than other birds
and if they can do that they will resume
that role now we get this question a lot
from ecologist people and this is
because
the old narrative of the passenger
pigeon the old narrative was that it was
a bird that had preferences for one
habitat versus another in that because
the habitat was changed it wasn't going
to work but because of our new data
there it's absolutely impossible for
them to have a preference for one forest
habitat over another and have that
population curve because the forest is
different today than it was a hundred
years ago but they were abundant ten
thousand years ago and 20 thousand years
ago and those forests were nothing like
they were in 1800s so the habitats they
were breeding in most commonly and in
1860 didn't exist fourteen thousand
years ago but there were just as many
birds so these are these are birds that
just seamlessly move from one habitat
type into another as climate is changing
it and other species are changing it and
they're playing a role as the ecosystem
engineer for whatever dominant tree type
is there been I liked it when you
described them as opportunists because I
think most people think about the birds
that they see is being hardwired to
migrate certain places for certain crops
at certain times of the year and the
passenger pigeon was really different
yeah it was it's one of the few bird
species in the world that is nomadic so
even though the name is migratorius
which is kind of redundant and so its
name ekta pissed 'yes migratorius means
though the wandering migrator and they
don't migrate that's just the thing
migration is a bird or a species going
from one set geographic location to
another set geographic location at the
same time every year without a miss
maybe you'll have a screwy one that goes
off somewhere else but the species does
that and that's why climate change is
such a huge deal rapid climate change to
some species because as they go back to
that same geologic a geographic location
it's now a different habitat passenger
pigeons aren't like that when you go
through the records and Shorter's book
there's records of them being in New
York in December in January or Michigan
in April or February or Mississippi at
the same months as those they're there
no matically going wherever they want
and so as things change they're free to
go wherever it's where it's good
question from Izzy well I think you
answered it already been I was going to
ask whether the missing chestnut from
the American woods would make
enough difference alone because they
were so dominant for so much of the
century
so our dietary research shows that they
definitely were capable of eating
chestnuts no I that was shocking to me
because I originally came in thinking
they didn't eat chestnuts they're big
yeah you look at them and they're
they're big but it's possible and the
thing is in historic records there's no
field observation of a passenger pigeon
eating a chestnut and there's only a
single chestnut ever found in a gut
cavity and so I believe there is
something happening that they're not
eating chestnuts the way they were and
this would make sense and I'll say this
because I didn't show it in here but
diet was a huge component of my master's
thesis passenger pigeons most likely
destroyed everything they ate they
didn't when they when they get rid of it
not the other end there were no intact
seeds chestnuts were the most abundant
tree while the passenger pigeons were
abundant or maybe three billion
chestnuts when there were three billion
passenger pigeons well there cannot be 3
billion prey in the face of 3 billion
predators
that's 100% impossible in every
ecosystem on the planet therefore
chestnuts had to be evading passenger
pigeon consumption somehow could you
talk a little bit about potentially
unintended consequences I could think of
3 things off the bat one of them is that
birds carry diseases another is that big
flocks of birds fly into airplanes and
make them crash a third is Alfred
Hitchcock's movie the birds and my mom
brings that ok so yeah and I'll offer a
few more so so evaluating risk is
something very important and it's why
important my management is is very
important so there's no evidence that
our new birds could fly all the way west
and interact with band-tailed pigeons
but let's assume they do let's assume a
few of our new passenger pigeons cross
the Great Plains in the mountains and
they meet some band-tailed pigeons and
our traits that we've engineered are so
successful that all band-tailed pigeons
in the West over several generations
become passenger pigeons and we've
caused the extinction of the band-tailed
as it was that's something to worry
about it's unlikely to happen
ecologically and it's something we need
to maintain and manage as far as those
other things I mean you know if they
become too abundant the thing to
remember and it's something we don't
like thinking about but hunting in the
United States is a conservation tool and
I already know lots of people who want
to hunt passenger pigeons when they can
someday the extinction of this species
happened with muzzleloading shotguns we
can keep them in check today they're not
an outbreak species that's that's gonna
get out of hand I was hunting elk last
week and the day after I left my dad
bagged a big one
archery wear traditional archers so the
airplanes
so the airplanes landing and taking off
would be a risk we all know that the one
plane that the movie is about right now
Sully hit Birds one good thing about
passenger pigeons and band-tailed
pigeons today too is that there are
fairly reclusive birds that prefer and
you might not believe this because
you'll see band-tailed pigeons in your
backyard but breeding flocks at
band-tailed pigeons prefer remote
habitat so it's unlikely that large
flocks will be really near airports and
urban areas a great deal but they're
also a low flying bird
so for high flying planes they're not
necessarily a risk but once again that's
something that has to be managed but
that's not something that's difficult
once they're abundant and here's what
I'll say passenger pigeons pose more
risk when they're rare than when they're
abundant it's this sweet spot think
about it this way the birds come in they
destroy forests and they poop a lot what
if that happens to Central Park New York
no one's gonna like that but I've
calculated that nearly something like
300 or 400 million birds could nest in
Central Park New York but Central Park
New York is hundreds of miles from
available food they cannot raise young
they're at saturation so if when we
create a flock that's larger than
saturation it can no longer live in
Central Park and it won't go there
so we need to create a flock that's
large enough to where they cannot
utilize human-made habitats the way
rarer birds could and that'll be the key
thing is abundance yeah I wanted to ask
you you obviously are working on the
scientific side of this but I take it
that you work with historical ecologists
as well to understand the ecology of
previous generations and I'm wondering
how much of that knowledge comes from
indigenous populations who have lived in
a pre European invasion in the
environments that we're talking about
when these birds were clearly just as
abundant as they are now and what has
that evidence said about the kinds of
ecologies in which they live and what
trees for example they've been crashing
to the ground
so that is sadly something we haven't
gotten to do yet this is partially
because we haven't been able to talk to
a lot of those researchers who work with
indigenous peoples I would well I
actually want to I've called I've
finally gotten in contact with one of
the first nations tribes that has an
intimate history with passenger pigeons
to start this dialogue also because I
feel they can be strong allies for the
future of this project this was their
bird for 10,000 years before it was ours
and what is known in the published
passenger pigeon literature is very very
little it's almost like everything that
indigenous peoples ever knew about the
birds was wiped off the face of the
planet when their cultures were nearly
decimated so hopefully we can learn some
new insights from from the indigenous
peoples but right now it's just been
going through literature to try and
identify who who do we even talk to and
if there's anyone else anyone alive that
that would have any connection to that
alright last question for me then you've
just completed your masters you've shown
us your last four years of work thank
you very much
what happens next for you well on
October 31st so work starting tomorrow I
will be applying for a scholarship to go
to Australia for a PhD and this is not
to be a student in the way that I was
here because I actually I'll admit I
really hate grad school I do I hate
every aspect
and I think the American graduate school
system is a sham taking advantage of
students so but the best best science
comes out of it I'm not saying it's
horrible
but when when Tim Duran a scientist at a
government lab in Australia approached
me he loves our project he wants to see
it go forward in his lab works on on
engineering birds and they want to go
beyond the chicken they want to go to
the pigeon and he said you know if you
came down here we could put some
Australian money into it and we could
get some this is Melbourne near
Melbourne it's near Melbourne Joe long
that's how they say it Joe long Victoria
so I went down there in February and I
trained and so the idea of being a
student there is that by being a student
we can get scholarship money to then
supplement the project in Australia and
it would bring me down there because
that's a government lab they can't just
hire me but they can they can allow
students to be hosted and I said when he
first said come down and do a PhD I said
no I said nope I don't need one I don't
care I've gotten this far without one
and he said oh no it's different down
here you don't have to take any classes
and I said sign me up
all right to be continued yes so Stuart
do you want to come I want to get the
photo up of the whole revive team up
here with with our auto drawing of the
the passenger pigeon and Ryan I think
you've got a little presentation so for
Ben on behalf of long now the board the
members and revive and restore a
challenge coin for you
thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]